Hello world it's or Raj and school of
Ai is a nonprofit organization I've
created for our community.
I am now looking for wizards to help
host regular in-person learning meetups
across the world. Link to sign up is
going to be in the video description.
We have a very simple mission and that's
to offer a worldclass AI education to
anyone on earth for free.
Our doors are open to all
those who wish to learn.
We are a learning community that spans
almost every country dedicated to
teaching our students how to make a
positive impact in the world using AI
technology, whether that's through
employment or entrepreneurship.
There are seven values that
we share in common. First,
we embrace the weird,
whether it's experiencing a new learning
style concept or idea that's completely
different than what we're used to.
We embrace it because we believe that
radically new approaches often result in
radical improvement.
Second,
we inspire and educate whatever
content we make, be it a blog, post,
video, live, talk or tweet.
We aim for it to both inspire
and educate developers. Third,
we have Beta driven optimism.
So much of modern day journalism focuses
on all the things wrong with the world.
But if we look at the data,
the quality of human life across a wide
range of metrics has radically improved
over the past 100 years.
Fourth,
we perform rapid experimentation
and idea alone is worth nothing.
It's the execution of it that matters.
And the best way to do that is to build,
assess,
and reiterate until we have a
valid solution to a problem.
Fifth,
we practice the art of frugality.
We know that a determined mind with
scarce resources can achieve seemingly
impossible things.
It's not necessary to make a lavish,
expensive purchases to live a
life of meaning and happiness.
Sixth, we choose love, not fear.
So much negativity in our lives
is caused by our own fear.
Dishonesty with ourselves and
with others on inability to learn,
missing out on great opportunities
when making decisions,
we make them out of love for
ourselves and for other humans.
And lastly, I'm inheriting this
one from my last workplace.
Twillio we draw the owl.
There's this meme that drawing an hour.
It takes a lot of instructions,
but we don't always have those
instructions available to us,
so we have to make them ourselves from
step draw a circle to the last step.
Draw the owl.
We figured the steps out as we need to.
I have a lot planned for
us in the coming months,
but a good first step to get the community
connected is to start school of Ai
meetups across the globe.
I'm looking for deans to help
me with this. Traditionally,
a dean is the head of a
department at a university.
Our deans will be the heads of their
cities school of Ai Chapter from Boston to
Berlin to Bombay.
They're responsible for hosting school
of Ai meetups in their respective city.
That means finding a suitable venue,
helping me promote the event locally
and helping other students in their
learning journey.
These meetups will also be an opportunity
for students to teach and share what
they've learned.
I will have a personal
line of communication with
all deans for support and
updates. Each meetup will consist
of either an educational lecture,
a hands on coding workshop,
or an AI research paper study session.
It's up to the dean to decide
what type of meetup it will be.
If you're selected to be a dean,
I'll provide you with a meetup page to
use and some resources to help you get
started hosting your first
school of Ai meetup. Get hype.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got a school to build,
so thanks for watching.